[Musique]
ah mon rêve est d'être
les footballeurs jouent dans de bons clubs tu sais
comme
Barcelone et
Et ici même à Tenerife
Canaria tu vas avec des amis, qu'est-ce que tu ne fais pas avec
amis avec des amis tu te retrouves j'y vais
pour dire que je t'apprends mon histoire de
d'amélioration afin qu'ils continuent comme
Je dis sur la route mais surtout
nous faisons un rituel de danse comme comment
nous le portons dans notre sang et c'est ce que nous
vous fait vous sentir comme chez vous et et
chaque jour nous le faisons
ici mais prends d'abord un bateau
qu'est-ce que tu vas penser, mourir, mourir la peur
mourir C'est la chose la plus terrible qui soit
Nous n'avions pas de psychologue sur le bateau.
nous n'avions rien, le chou drapeau
Sénégal que ni l'un ni l'autre Et qui fais-tu
insomnie si dans le cas des enfants
meilleurs cauchemars de terreurs nocturnes
hein à part les troubles mentaux
post-traumatique Eh bien, nous pouvons aussi
détecter les troubles du sommeil comme je l'ai dit
auparavant, euh, anxiété, dépression
L’étape du duel d’immigration évidemment
hein Et parfois dans des situations de deuil
la mort
familier
et donner de la motivation aux enfants qui
Ils viennent par derrière et te font ce sourire
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin et depuis pour moi
Ils l'ont donné d'une manière très très concise
le bonheur et j'en ai besoin aussi
avoir ce bonheur les gars quoi
le besoin est d'être entendu
parce qu'en fin de compte, c'est ce que chacun
ce dont nous avons besoin, pas ce que nous ressentons
entendu
euh, attrape ce dont tu as besoin dans ton esprit
ta pensée dans ton mouvement hein tout
ce sont les gestes qui font tout ça
parle